This is the Venus Demo. It was
discovered in an underground cavern on
the island of Milos a little over two
centuries ago. Most people think that
it's a sculpture and that it was
therefore made by a sculptor. But I'd
like to challenge this silly
superstition. I say there's no way the
Venus demo had a sculptor. Think about
it. What sort of sculptor would make a
statue of Venus
with no arms? You know as well as I that
any sculptor worthy of the name would
have put some arms on this thing. Since
we know that a sculptor would have made
a statue of Venus with arms and yet we
find no arms, it should be obvious to
everyone that the armlessness of this
whatever it is makes belief in a
sculptor completely irrational. The
Venus demo we observe has precisely the
properties we should expect if there is
at bottom no design, no purpose, no
chisels, no mallets, nothing but blind,
pitiles indifference. Now, some of you
may be thinking, well, sculptor did make
the statue with arms. They just fell off
later like that zombie's arm and
thriller.
But what conclusive scientific proof
have you been given that there were ever
arms on this marble monstrosity? You've
been given no conclusive scientific
proof, which means you believe by blind
faith that the Venus demo is a
sculpture. And if you're going to
believe that nonsense by blind faith,
you might as well believe in a flying
spaghetti sculptor and wear a spaghetti
strainer on your brainless head and eat
a big bowl of spaghettiios with all your
leprechaun friends over a Bigfoot's
house. Of course, sculptards everywhere
pretend that the Venus demo can only be
explained by appealing to an intelligent
designer. But one of the most
fundamental principles of atheistic
reasoning is that we should never use
intelligence to explain something when
there are perfectly good non-intelligent
explanations right at our fingertips,
which we have.
So what's our non-intelligent
explanation for the Venus demo? As
always, we shine our Darwin fish signal
up the clouds to alert the real hero of
every atheist comic book story, Captain
Chance. So, how can Captain Chance
explain something like the Venus Demo?
Easily. Rocks form in all kinds of
shapes and sizes, don't they? Surely,
given enough time and enough rocks
forming all over the planet, Captain
Chance would have no problem producing a
rock shaped exactly like this. If you
doubt the power of Captain Chance to
produce things that give the appearance
of design, welcome to the Dwood School
of Comparative Probability. Today's
lesson, the odds of the Venus demo
forming by chance are a joke compared to
the odds of the universe permitting
life. The constants of physics have to
be finely tuned with unimaginable
precision or we wouldn't be here. If
Captain Chance can scale that mountain
improbable, how much easier is it for
him to scale a hunk of marble shaped
like a deformed goddess? In case you're
still not convinced, think about life.
Even the simplest living cell is vastly
more sophisticated than the Venus do.
You'd get an army of Venus-shaped rocks
before you'd get a single living cell by
chance. Captain Chance has such
spectacular power to create life. How is
this pale imitation of life going to
stand in his way? Instead of doubting
our hero, Captain Chance, I say we give
him a promotion. He's major chance now.
Major Chance put around 6 ft of DNA in
each of your 20 to 40 trillion cells.
The DNA that Major Chance inserted into
each of your 20 to 40 trillion cells is
a set of instructions for building you.
Imagine scientists examining the Venus
demo and finding out that it's composed
of trillions of tiny parts and that each
of these trillions of tiny parts
contains a set of instructions for
building the entire thing. Even that
wouldn't be evidence for an intelligent
designer because you're composed of
trillions of tiny parts that contain
sets of instructions for building you.
And that's no evidence for an
intelligent designer, right? It's all
major chance. But in fact, there are no
tiny parts containing sets of
instructions here. It's a useless hunk
of marble.
Ladies and gentlemen, only a fool would
believe that this is really a sculpture
of Venus. Just as the defects in our
world prove that our world couldn't have
been created by God, so also the defects
of the Venus demo prove that it couldn't
have been made by a sculptor. Yet the
Venus delusion has infected billions of
weak minds. May seem like a harmless
delusion, but the results have been
catastrophic. All the millions of
combined hours people have spent staring
at this eyesore could have been spent
curing cancer. Cancer thus persists
because the Venus delusion persists. So
belief in a sculptor is not only stupid,
it's also dangerous. I now rest my
airtight case and I encourage you to
join me in endlessly ridiculing all the
pathetic brainwashed morons who share
the Venus delusion. Relentlessly mocking
them for believing in a magical sky
sculptor will help you feel good about
yourself without having to do the
difficult work of actually accomplishing
anything ever. This message has been
brought to you by a generous grant from
the Association of Richard Dawkins
Drones and the Society for the
Prevention of Common Sense.